okay we're not including any of that
conversation editor also write it in
resuming in three two one in literally
uplifting news permitted by cabs are
here
an eleven year old boy saved a man
drowning from the bottom of a pool oh
wow a grown-ass man do 11-year olds know
this one what was this one dead I've
seen like a freakin toddler swim oh
really oh you had a little baby
yeah they teach him how to just yeah
yeah so this little boy he's 11 years
old he weighs 80 pounds and he was able
to pull a 34 year old man that had sunk
to the bottom of an indoor pool at their
apartment complex in Minnesota
many shoulder deep end so it was about
eight feet down he was floating with his
hands stretched out his mouth and eyes
wide open there were other adults there
but no one could swim except for this 11
you're like I don't know a single cream
person that can swim what'd you say I
said I don't know a single Korean person
that can't swim I think it's just
because that's how we came here I'll
tell you why because we're in a
peninsula we're surrounded by water no I
thought it was because all Asian dads
threw their sons in the pool and forced
um I don't know this one yeah cuz my dad
was getting pissed that I was hanging by
the thing and he's like come here and he
grabbed me threw me in and he's like you
can swim and I was like choking and I
was like I gotta survive mother my dad
told me to go next to the pool and that
he kicked me inside oh wow he told me
that if I had to survive so I decided
yeah and I got to the edge he goes bad
right and it was terrible yeah is that
what that is no secondary drowning scary
because your kid takes in a little bit
of water and then he coughs up a little
bit and you're like oh he's fine I
vomited water and then later on the
night they pass away actually yeah like
there's water in their lungs with
children I was gonna do that to my kid I
mean I would never do that and I was a
swimmer for [ __ ] my whole life and I
would never never never just throw my
kid now yeah but I love the water now
though if I were the parent of this 11
year old kid I would never allow my kids
who rescue a man well the boarders
actually told them to go in the mom I
would never because if if you've never
seen a drowning situation people are
frantic and they're in survival mode
they will drag you down they will drown
the person that's trying to save them
Louie I would never go without you know
floatable devices around me if I wasn't
trained already to be like a life all
right that's just danger danger see you
go down when you swim with the 25 pound
dumbbell you put it on his throat you
knock him out and you've dragged him up
yeah we put in this case is stroke or
something and he fell what if the 11
year all it was Michael Phelps when he
was 11 you would do it then champion
yeah I would Fischer do it if he was
already unconscious hmm I don't know if
he was on I just pictured an old man
with a pina colada and you had a stroke
and he fall inside like then you fell
inside you got oh and then he goes oh no
we gotta save him and then [ __ ]
Baywatch
if dudes at the bottom of the pool I
think he's unconscious I think was okay
yeah so they say that there are at least
nine men around the pool up wrong not
nice can't swim listen if you can't swim
fine but can't you get in the water and
like stretch your leg out in leg yeah
yeah if you can't swim that and at an
adult age you're probably really scared
of water yeah point so I guarantee this
man is dying would you have to stick
your leg out yeah like I would get in
the water hold onto the edge and like
stick my body I didn't know how to swim
Tim I really doubt it I think I would I
think it was feet of water you know you
would be scared of it here I mean but
they feet of water right and then
however tall he is
and then however long I am pretty sure
if you could grab him yeah but what if
he drags your ass down you're [ __ ]
most pools have that pole thing on the
side also so you should just take the
buoy yeah and then go get [ __ ] the buoy
he's dead leave him what I'm saying he's
dead but he wasn't dead he's alive right
yes he saved him yeah he made a full
recovery
what did he do like CPR here more like
so this kid's name is advic and so we go
what a dope name what is it super yummy
he's an Israeli superhero no from India
okay how does it has a product yeah
Arabic is 11 years old and lastly I'll
be oh it's easy it's so easy his name is
adria kuku
what is it infamous Nandi code hi look
at that luscious hair though jealous
dear so proud bad asked us if you know
of grown man Saudis the best drowning
the mom told him oh they were Indian
then go get him mom immediately was like
hey do you know how to so you've been
taking so many lessons recently like go
in there that's it with just one
swimming lessons dad uses donor on swim
he immediately says like I think he's
too heavy for me but thank you jumped in
anyway I don't think he jumped and I
think his mom pushed behind basil or
that he was able to go to the bottom of
the pool and pull him out Wow yeah like
he pulled him out and see what a star is
strong so it makes uncle he goes over
and he starts like pounding on his chest
and that is not how you do it they don't
know how to do CPR but they also said
like his father and makes father tried
to save the man by jumping in with the
floating tube but then it it was pushing
him up and then he was able to grab him
oh so his parents didn't know how to
swim yeah no no one around like at least
nine men were there and the mother and
no one knew him we got to continue to
take his swimming lessons so he could
save people yeah and then now his whole
family is taking swimming lessons just
type I mean how arrogant are we is like
a human race at seventy percent of this
earth is made up of water and you just
don't you know know how to swim sorry
dude I know you guys are learning I mean
I know how to not drown like yeah
I can't swim you've gone to Hawaii with
us yeah but I wouldn't say I'm a strong
swimmer does it feel confident but you
can still swim them she could swim she
could save someone if I need big if I
threw you off a [ __ ] ball I'm living
not living some like to me like when
people say oh I know how to swim getting
from point A to point B is not knowing
how to sense what I'm saying I don't
know that's not so that's not that
doesn't serve you at all in a survival
situation knowing how to float and relax
loading so [ __ ] easy it's unreal
Jackie buoyant my bones are hollow even
now yeah you should try now there's no
substance in my bones whatsoever you're
like chicken bones yeah I just float to
the top like mega osteoporosis easy
maybe I could swim on you can I'm very
good very wet I'm very buoyant that was
I mean you float very well have a high
lipid Cohen blob very well yeah you do
yeah I like to serve I never learn how
to swim properly I'll be cool there's
better techniques because most of us are
learning naturally through trial in
there yeah that's what I do
so like when I have Isaac on my back and
I'm swimming froggy style doing all this
stuff it's easy technique walking back
in Prague is good you know what kalila
was in a you know olympic swimmer do you
guys know that yeah but she was on the
beam she was on the National Philippine
team Oh go to the [ __ ] Olympics all
right good all right and then she met
that's what it is she's legit
you did one of these the opposite
otherwise you know 200-meter butterfly
er that's a dispensation so you know
like that limp excites pulling long ways
that's there and back twice it's
actually four times yeah I mean we're in
Hawaii felt swimming with the sharks
right free swim with sharks in the cage
no no cage thank this lady right it's
like up woman she's on the bottom
collecting mussels you mean sing hi to
the shark is myself I was so scared why
would you be next to sharks you look
like a seal in the water would you say
seals are [ __ ] the door yeah but I
look like a fat seal in the water a
dialysis seal please [ __ ] you look baby
thank you yeah thank you he's been
[ __ ] punking you all night dude I
would never Punk my sensor do you
understand me this man right here kid
right here dude
he's you're [ __ ] up I talk to him
like that we have a [ __ ] connection
just like it's not like this is more
like this he's your oppa yeah you're
disrespectful Connie honey
the Booya whatever your name is you're
really good everything cuz you swam next
to the sharks you wouldn't like urgent
hunting and [ __ ] yeah I get lobster
she's amazing how the [ __ ] aren't you
scared of the open water yeah it's
always in the back of my mind you know
that California is the home to a great
white shark
yes but the likelihood is so low I don't
you know we just yeah you tell that to
that little girl that got eaten up in
the water here it's so murky that's when
I don't go out when the water is murky
is when it becomes dangerous I mean if
you're going to Hawaii that's different
yeah the clarity is really good that
those sharks are bright they see you
they will want you yeah it's murky and
it becomes an accident they actually
chomp that's what everybody says and
they die
kalila I'll put it to you like that you
swam with 30 sharks none of them even
came close to what kind of sharks too if
they're Galapagos they're real they're
some occasionally they have Tiger come
around
they're hyper aggressive type of sharks
there's the most bites with tiger sharks
because they have the worst eyesight and
then they tend to feed around where
people surf because of seals and turtles
oh my god sharks have different teeth
there's a shortage that they have
uniform like incisors like they have
maybe why'd you do that
did you fight oh my god you son of a
[ __ ] hey I don't want to smell it
[Music]
you